so you can see a skull very clearly up
there
and actually if you look closely you can
see there's a number of other bones long
bones
bones of the foot so whole pile of bones
here
this is ella al-shamahi she's standing
on a rocky hillside next to a big cliff
face
an archaeologist named ahmed is showing
her this narrow opening in the cliff
it's right at eye level and it looks
just big enough that someone could
shimmy inside
but ella isn't going in she's just
peeking what's this
there is a bone here that's a human
finger
or a foot bone
ella is on an island called sakotra and
the hole she's looking at
someone used it as a gravesite it looks
like several people were buried inside
this cave
a long time ago so there's a grave here
the good thing is this grave looks like
it hasn't been disturbed so that's great
but
this whole cliff face is full of these
graves in these
caves and quite a few of them have
actually been looted quite considerably
so
that's quite sad ella is an
archaeologist
so to her these graves could hold
valuable information
maybe there are clues about who these
people are or how they wound up buried
in the side of a cliff
i think the question is how old this is
and ahmad told me that there's no dates
on this so they're not sure
looking at it it does definitely look
pre-islamic which would mean
several hundred years old or more
but elle is here to search for something
even older
she wants to find traces of our
ancestors the first humans to leave
africa and spread across the world she's
looking for them here on socotra
it's part of yemen a country going
through a brutal civil war
so what do you do when following your
research leads you to a war zone
i'm amy briggs and this is overheard at
national geographic
a show where we eavesdrop on the wild
conversations we have at nachio
and follow them to the edges of our big
weird beautiful world
this week what happens when the perfect
place to do research
is a place most people want to avoid the
search for stepping stones out of africa
the ways war hinders scientific
discovery and the people working to
change that
[Music]
more after the break
the thing with humans is we are bizarre
and we are curious you know what was the
insanity that went through a homo
sapiens
head to get on some kind of a raft and
just go
screw it let's just let's just keep
sailing and see what happens
ella al-shavahi spends a lot of time
thinking about our ancestors baffling
decisions
her official job title is
paleoanthropologist
which is a fancy way of saying i guess
that i'm an archaeologist who studies
um human evolution she's also a national
geographic explorer
ella grew up in the uk but both of her
parents are from yemen and she used to
go visit her family there
like as an archaeologist when i walk
through my
uh dad's um city
i'm just sitting there going i can't
this looks like something from the old
testament it's
mad when ella was an undergraduate she
realized she could use her background to
her advantage
i was really interested in how humans
left africa
um and just because of my family
ancestry is yemeni i kept looking at
this
this map um and everybody kept saying oh
we're going up
you know we went we left via the sinai
of egypt that's the classic textbook
explanation of how humans first left
africa
but ella she focused on another part of
the map
there's a narrow stretch of water
separating yemen from africa it's close
enough
that maybe humans made it across maybe
it's another route out of africa
it's not that far um it's not that deep
and so you know it did get me thinking
paleoanthropology has one thing in
common with real estate
it all boils down to location location
location
and as far as ella is concerned yemen is
in just the right place
it's on the arabian peninsula wedged
into a corner of the indian ocean
at its closest point it's just 20 miles
away from the eastern coast of africa
so it's right in the transition area
where two continents meet
the problem now is getting to yemen the
civil war makes it extremely dangerous
for outsiders
and i guess just because i'm yemeni
right it didn't it didn't seem
as risky for me because i'm also okay
it's the place where you know
some colleague got kidnapped but also
it's the place where my cousin got
married so it's kind of
it it demystifies this place
for several years most of yemen has been
too dangerous even for ella
but that doesn't mean the whole country
is off limits socotra is about 200 miles
off yemen's coast
it's about the same size as long island
new york but the landscape couldn't be
more different
to yemeni people socotra has a
reputation as a wild and wonderful place
somebody once told me that um sokotra
was the kind of island that if a child
drew an island
that's the and i'm like yes that is
exactly right you've got crazy canyons
you've got crazy desert like things
you've got a beach that's basically like
a mountain desert it's just as
it just looks bizarre
socotra has tall jagged mountains and
wide rocky plateaus
and all over this island are plants and
animals only found here in the wild
ninety percent of the island's reptiles
don't live anywhere else on earth
but if i had to pick a favorite critter
i wouldn't be a rare
bird or a lizard it would be a bug
the monocentropus belfory otherwise
known as the
socotra island blue baboon spider it's
big
it's blue it's hairy it's a tarantula
and it is the most beautiful blue spider
i've ever seen
there is so much unique life that people
call socotra the galapagos of the indian
ocean
blue spiders aside there's one plant
that overshadows almost everything else
it's called the dragon's blood tree
aside from having a great name it has a
very memorable appearance
so imagine this you're looking at
socotra's dry rocky landscape
and from it grows something that looks
like a gnarly pine tree
and a mushroom had a baby it has a
twisted brown trunk
standing about as tall as a person and
at the top of this trunk
intertwined branches grow up and out
almost like an umbrella
and then up on top is a carpet of leaves
that look like
thin piney needles but wait there's more
if you cut open this tree it kind of
looks like a crime scene
the sap is blood red but it's this sap
that gives the dragon's blood tree it's
fantastic name
and this sap has been used for centuries
for all kinds of things it's been a
medicine
it's been a dye it's been in makeup and
it's also been in a varnish
so ella wanted to see it all for herself
put it like this if sokotra was in the
middle of europe there would be
a number a number of scientists working
there in every corner of it
all through the year in 2018 ella
traveled there on a scouting trip
basically a fact-finding mission to lay
the groundwork for a bigger full-scale
scientific expedition
i was being told that once you get to
socotra
it's safe the problem is getting to
socotra violence can flare up at yemen's
airports so flying felt risky
she checked out a couple of flight paths
and ruled out both and so there was this
third option that was really out there
but i was aware that some other
scientists had done it and it was their
idea it really wasn't our idea
instead of flying they could sail to
socotra
but it wouldn't be a pleasure cruise in
fact it wouldn't even be
a passenger boat ella and her three
teammates boarded a cargo ship
hauling cement a cement cargo ship which
i really need to explain is not fit for
purpose
i mean these things are you know just
oh i mean you know they're something
else
they're cockroach infested i really do
mean that um
i mean i have stories um and the toilet
is effectively a basket on the side
of the ship that's welded on with very
questionable
welding and ropes and it's got a hole in
it
and obviously you know it's efficient
yeah yeah it was something it was
it was memorable
there were other negatives too serious
ones
the waters around sokotra are called the
arabian sea
it's a place where pirates sometimes
attack ships sailing through
i mean we were quite up to date on kind
of pirate
activities in the area and what happened
we thought they were lower than
previous years certainly um but
there's absolutely no doubt that we were
taking a risk in fact
that year three ships in the region
reported pirates shooting at them
ella's team made it to socotra unharmed
but that's a lot of risk to take on in
the name of science
so it's no wonder that not many
researchers even try to go
some scientists want to change that but
ella says
there are barriers standing in the way
barriers too big for one person to take
down
so in america and in the uk
um it's very very difficult to work in
more unstable parts of the world
um our departments our universities and
our funding bodies as well as our
government sometimes actually make it
really really difficult in fact
there's a lot of grants that you simply
can't get if you say you're working in
an unstable part of the world
ella says there's no question that her
work involves risks
but so does some other research like
handling poisonous animals
or exploring deep caves institutions
will fund that research
but they're more hesitant to fund the
kind ella is talking about
she says that creates a blind spot in
the western science world
a blind spot to places we deem too
dangerous i
believe firmly that science has a
geography problem
and so if you were to take out a map
right now and you were to cross out
all the places which are unstable
hostile or disputed
you're actually looking at quite a
significant part of our planet
especially areas in africa and the
middle east
ella says the science world has created
a vicious cycle
scientists can get money to work in
safer places so that's where they work
more attention means better results so
working in safe places
seems to lead to a good outcome
meanwhile the country is seen as
dangerous
well they get less attention less
research means lower chances of making a
new discovery
so it can seem like those places aren't
worth the trouble and what we're just
gonna not do as much science in all of
these places
that's surely a tragedy for science it's
also
you know a tragedy for those places
knocking down the geography problem
it's not something that will happen
overnight but it is possible to make a
dent
even if it's only one researcher at a
time
i i mean i come from a war zone and i
was
trying to go back at some point to do
something good
this is sada mirei i thought i would be
back as
a doctor or a human rights lawyer
but today sarah isn't a doctor or a
lawyer she's an archaeologist
the war zone she came from is somalia
just across the water from yemen
for more than a decade she's been the
only native somali archaeologist working
there
we have often an image of
conflict zones that it's a no-no
area and i can understand those conflict
zones can definitely be dangerous
but often there are safer areas pockets
where a scientist can work
there are millions of people living in
these places they're not just
you know they're not just abandoned war
zones
so when sada was getting her phd she
told her british university
i want to work on somali archaeology in
this independent region called
somaliland
the university didn't want to give her
permission to go at sata says
it was nearly impossible to secure
funding but somali people
they saw that she was onto something
sata's first project was like a
grassroots archaeological survey
her family drove her all around the
countryside and sought to ask strangers
if they knew where she could find rock
art
i had an album with pictures of all
sorts of archaeological sites all over
the world
i had one picture of stonehenge and i
was walking around saying have you seen
anything like this here
or some something with rock art and and
the rock art they would say oh yes
you're looking for the devil's hole
little by little sata built up
archaeology in somaliland
she says it's crucial for somali people
to be the ones doing research
for one thing she realized that she was
thinking about archaeology all wrong
just like many other people i was
banging my head against the wall
thinking
why aren't people mad about the fact we
have lost so many sides
that the museum have been looted but
sada realized
it wasn't all about old artifacts dug
out of the ground
instead she started focusing on somali
heritage
what people passed down from generation
to generation so for example i'm i'll be
excavating iron tools or pottery
but then there will be pockets of
community
who really have sustained traditional
iron smelting
or pottery making so this is the way
they are preserving and there is a rich
oral culture
and this you will never see in an
archaeological site unless you have this
whole
knowledge that whole knowledge
it's something local scientists have in
a way that outsiders often don't
that's another reason to support local
scientists instead of just bringing in
people from outside
sata says uncovering somali heritage has
taught her that the country really needs
more people like her
more archaeologists more scientists we
have
as human beings not only a need for
food and shelter but also a need for
each other and that is actually
the the sense of community the way we
build a sense of communities through
culture
and she says scientists can help with
that
since sata started in 2007 archaeology
in the region has come a long way
she doesn't have to show photos of
stonehenge to strangers anymore
instead she's rolling out a new website
with 3d scans of somali archaeological
sites
sata fought back against the geography
problem and on sakotra
ella al-shamahi thinks she can too and
for me the question was
when did humans get to this island
genetics research suggests only a few
thousand years ago
which is pretty recent if you consider
that homo sapiens have been around for
about 300 000 years
but ella says genetic analysis doesn't
tell the whole story
she wants to know what's buried in the
ground it's an island that's very very
close
to africa and yet um
the archaeology there isn't well dated
at all
so she teamed up with the guy who knows
the coach's archaeology better than
anybody
ahmed al-arkaby a moment
generally speaking socotra is untouched
it continues to be unstudied
ahmed is the archaeologist who showed
ella those burials inside the caves
he runs the local government department
of antiquities and he's one of socotra's
only archaeologists
in the ancient world the island was a
busy stopover for sailors
people visited from all over africa and
the middle east and from as far away as
greece and india
this island is unique in terms of its
natural setting the culture of its
peoples and their language
and the distinct cultural heritage
that's found here it's unlike any other
area within
or outside of yemen this island needs to
document these sites
ahmed has logged almost 500
archaeological sites on socotra
and he says some of them are totally
stunning there's two thousand year old
rock art depicting animals and human
stick figures
there are ancient burial sites and ruins
of old towns
there's so much to work with but ahmed
can't do it all by himself
take this one time when he was working
on his master's degree
he decided to catalog as many rock art
sites as he could across every nook and
cranny of the island
i did this for a full month researching
field visits throughout the different
regions of sakoto well
one day i decided to chat with some of
my friends about what i was working on
who knows perhaps one of them had seen
some site or another
so ahmed showed pictures of rock art to
his friends and one guy was like oh yeah
i know exactly what you're talking about
there's a spot really close to here
ahmed was skeptical he wasn't convinced
that this guy knew what he was talking
about
but his friend just wouldn't let it go
i said all right fine we'll take my car
and we can go to whatever area you want
this was out of civility and courtesy
because i was thinking that this guy
like probably doesn't know anything
about this subject he's just a simple
average guy
so they drove to a spot just a few miles
outside sokotra's capital city
basically right in akhman's backyard
they got out of the car
and the guy was like here it is
when we arrived i was shocked utterly
stunned
i was astounded at the amount and
variety of the drawings that were there
like the drawings found at this location
are unlike anywhere else
so picture a field part of it's grassy
part of it's rocky
so the rocks on the ground there's this
spidery
chicken scratch marking all over them
some of the markings seem to be drawings
of plants like a palm leaf that looks
like a
kind of like a simple cartoon christmas
tree in another area
it looks like somebody drew life-sized
feet into the rock
some of them even have little toes
etched in and there's a lot more
like dozens of christian crosses even a
drawing of a ship
all of that just in the ground right
there
and it would have been almost impossible
to discover unless you knew where to
look
so without even thinking i hugged this
friend of mine so tight
his head got so big more than once i
thanked him profusely and apologized for
not listening to him the first time
this turned out to be the second largest
rock art site on the entire island
the oldest drawings could date back to
the 300s a.d
and finding it was a big deal in fact
ahmed found out that a foreign
researcher had been searching for this
rock art for years
the researcher knew it existed but he
assumed it had been destroyed when
someone built a factory nearby
so i showed him my photos and he was
amazed and said to me
i've spent more than 10 years looking
for this place but haven't found it
how did you stumble upon this site and i
said to him
because you all you rely on old maps
created by foreigners
you don't depend on the locals the
locals are the ones who really know the
area
but finding it was only half the battle
protecting it is the other
this site was in danger of being totally
wiped out by a planned construction
project
this kind of threat is a constant
problem for socotra's ancient sites
so it's up to ahmed and some locals to
make sure this site stays safe
ahmed convinced the local government to
build a wall around the site
hopefully it will stay intact but this
is just
one site one out of almost 500.
there are a number of sites here that
need protection need field visits
need research need study and god willing
the research will come to fruition but
ahmed
he can't do it alone he says that he has
no budget for all of that work he wants
help from outside scientists
but they don't visit often that's where
ella al-shamahi comes in
after her scouting expedition she wants
to go back to sakotra
and to bring more scientists with her
she's planning the biggest expedition to
the island in more than 20 years
but due to the covet 19 pandemic there's
no telling when her team will be able to
go
plus there's always a chance that war
could flare up and make sakota unsafe
for me just personally as somebody of
yemeni ancestry
um at some point this bloody war will be
over
and it breaks my heart to kind of talk
about it but
at some point it will be over and when
it's over
i know from experience and working in
other parts of the world
that often not always but often world
heritage sites
are um are one of the few things
that people can actually agree on and
warring parties and tribes can actually
agree on
and unpacking human history in yemen she
thinks that's something people can get
behind
thanks to her scouting expedition ella
knows exactly where she wants to dig
she identified caves that she calls
prime real estate
places where you'd expect ancient humans
to live
what other chances you know how deep is
that sediment and how much of that
sediment will be filled with old stuff
basically
ella says the thought gives her
goosebumps
she doesn't know what she might find or
if she'll find anything at all
but to discover our early ancestors and
to learn more about the history of
humans in yemen
she has to keep digging and the thing
that i always say about
paleoanthropology
is it's like somebody has given you a
few pieces of a jigsaw puzzle
but they haven't told you how much of
the jigsaw they've given you
so the question is how big is that
jigsaw
there's only one way to find out we have
to keep looking for the puzzle pieces
wherever they might be
more after the break
now that you've heard about socotra
you've got to see it for yourself
check out the link in our show notes to
a story about the island and see the
dragon's blood trees through the eyes of
a nachio photographer
also learn more about the human journey
out of africa
in yemen's neighbor saudi arabia
scientists discovered human footprints
that are more than a hundred thousand
years old
that's the oldest trace of humans found
in the arabian peninsula
the oldest so far anyway and we also
have stories about yemen's civil war
you can see the work of a yemeni
photographer who looks for points of
light in the war's darkness
and for subscribers you can see a rare
dispatch from life on the front lines of
yemen's civil war that's all in the show
notes
right there on your podcast app
[Music]
overheard at national geographic is
produced by brian gutierrez
jacob pinter and laura sim our senior
editor is eli chen
executive producer of audio is davar
ardalan
our fact-checkers are michelle harris
and robin palmer
our copy editor is amy kolczak hansdale
sue composed our theme music and
engineers our episodes
thanks to rhys thwaites jones for the
field audio from sakotra
and to alex brock for helping with
arabic translation
the national geographic society is
committed to illuminating and protecting
the wonder of our world and funds the
work of explorer ella al-shamahi
this podcast is a production of national
geographic partners
whitney johnson is the director of
visuals and immersive experiences
susan goldberg is national geographic's
editorial director
and i'm your host amy briggs thanks for
listening and see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you